Speaker 1: OK, we're going to look today at
a few clips and listen to a few clips from
a recent interview that Candace Owens did with
Eric Trump Jr. I guess, I guess Eric Trump did
the interview with Candace Owens. Candace is the
interviewer is the point I'm trying to make and
what I want you to think about. Here are really
two things. There's two takeaways here. You know,
Candace Owens is this right wing grifter. It's not
even clear she's really right wing. It seems that
this is a business model that she stumbled
across. She claims that she used to be on
the left. Now she's on the right. The explanation
never really makes sense. This really seems to be
mostly a business thing for her, and she will
say anything. I mean, she said after Bob Saget
died, it seems like it was related to the vaccine.
Of course it was. There was no evidence of that.
And now we know that it was actually, you know,
a hit to the head of absolutely no standards.
She will go lower, doesn't matter. She will
say anything that that will get attention.
She interviewed Eric Trump, and there's a couple
different things to pay attention to here.
One is this interview you? This is so important
to understand this interview counts as deep,
serious intellectual discourse for the right
and for Republicans at this point in time. Now,
I assert that this is the epitome of pabulum.
I mean, this is trash worthless discussion.
But also look at the way in which they pander. In
this particular first clip, we're going to look at
to the religious wing of the Republican
Party. But in such a transparent way,
that nut, you would have to suspend all
disbelief and skepticism to think that
Eric Trump is even remotely serious about his
religiosity here. So let's just jump right in.
It'll all be be made very clear here. You can have
Speaker 2: dinner with anybody dead or
alive. You can't say Trump. You can't
rule you out, Trump, but you can't
say your father. We had dinner with him
Speaker 3: plenty of time. How about Jesus?
Speaker 2: Jesus? OK, so
Speaker 1: Jesus is who, Eric?
If he could pick anybody to have dinner with, he
would have dinner with Jesus. Now we all know this
is not a religious family. Trump didn't go to
church. His kids didn't go to church. This is a
character they've developed since entering
Republican politics. But what gives it away
is this next part? Take a listen.
Speaker 3: Good answer. Happy a good one, Ryan.
Speaker 2: What would you ask them?
Speaker 3: Did you envision this happening
to the United States of America and
did you ever envision a person as incompetent
as Joe Biden running the United States of
America? How in the world did this happen? Right?
Speaker 1: You can tell how deeply spiritual he
is from the question he would ask Jesus. And
of course, it all. This is the sort of sophist
facade that these guys and gals try to
put up there. Well, there's no one other.
Jesus is the top person I would like to have
dinner with, really? And what would you ask
them? Not what is the meaning of life?
What is the origin of the universe? Well,
you know not. Why? Why does why does God allow
bad things to happen? No, the question would be,
did you ever imagine an incompetent Joe Biden
would be the president of the United States?
That's the one question you ask Jesus. If you sit
down with him, it's unbelievable. I mean, it's
who could possibly fall for this stuff, but they
see this and they go, This is a religious family.
This is deep intellectual discussion.
Speaker 3: I honestly, I might ask him
if this is actually a ploy to show people the
difference between Republican leadership and
Democratic leadership right now. Sometimes, a
Speaker 1: God selected Biden to show how
much better Republicans are. That's
that's obviously the concern of Jesus.
Speaker 3: Think about that. Is this part of
the you have Donald Trump who had just four
years of into spite of everything they tried to
do to destroy him again? Greatest unemployment
manufacturing was coming back to this country.
Speaker 1: Remember, this is still all.
What would you ask, Jesus?
Speaker 3: You know, stability
in the Middle East to the likes of which we've
never seen before, and you just go through all
the accomplishments. And then in about three
weeks, this guy comes in and you've got,
you know, gas prices double and you have
inflation absolutely through the roof and
you have the loss of civil liberties. I mean,
Speaker 1: not only should you ask Jesus about
gas prices, ask about his view on leaded
versus unleaded and ask about ethanol to
Speaker 3: you have crime going
through the roof. You've got
Christmas prices that can't be delivered
because Larry store shelves are empty because
Speaker 1: so you guys get it. So this counts
a serious discussion on the right and then it
gets even crazier where Eric Trump says that
the COVID vaccine represents the stripping of
freedoms in the country in a literal sense. OK.
The vaccine, which his dad invented according
to what they say and should get praise for,
also is the literal stripping of our freedoms.
Speaker 3: The problem I have with it is. It's
contradictory to their own message, which is
strong, like you've got to be consistent in the
life, you know, you can't waver every single day,
but I think beyond that is a greater
reflection on kind of where we are
as America, if they're willing to strip
your rights to your own health care. Well,
what are they willing to do with religion? What
are they willing to do the Second Amendment?
What are they willing to do to our constitution?
Speaker 1: Really a deep thinker, as you guys can
tell. And even Candace Owens seems bored
by this. By the way, if you're watching,
Speaker 3: we all know the answer to those
questions, right? And it's deeply scary. But
to me, the vaccine actually represents something
that's much greater than a medical shot. To me,
the vaccine represents literally the stripping
of freedoms in this country, which is now all
Speaker 1: of a sudden, Candace Owens perks up.
Now she's nodding. Yeah, oh yeah. The vaccine,
that's it. Is the stripping of freedoms.
Exactly. This guy is obviously vaccinated
like the whole Trump family, like Trump himself.
He knows it works. He got the vaccine. But this
is the red meat to stay on message,
Speaker 3: which is deeply, deeply,
deeply troubling. And you see it every single
day. You see it. As he ripped down these statues
of Thomas Jefferson and Abraham Lincoln and George
Washington all over the country now, why are they
doing the why are they? Why are they ripping down
statues? Because they want to rewrite our history.
They want to rewrite or simply release even.
Speaker 1: This is like a distortion because
you guys know and we've we followed the
the overwhelming. I don't even know.
Maybe a Lincoln statue was taken down. I
don't know. I've certainly not heard of it,
maybe a Washingtons that I don't know
anything. I've not heard that. But the
whole statue controversy was really about
Confederate statues and schools named after
pro-slavery Confederate generals. That's really
what this was about. But they can't say that
Trump sometimes would talk about it, but
they can't really say that. So they say
they're trying to erase Abe Lincoln. But
all of this is a distortion. All of it
Speaker 3: want to rewrite our constitution so
they can make the very people that they rip down.
They can make them martyrs. Well, then he can
make the documents that they wrote into kind of,
you know, martyr documents. They can change
those documents, right? It gives them
the rehabilitation of the ability.
Speaker 1: So anyway, as you can tell,
Eric Trump is not the smart one. He's not the
articulate one. What he's saying is making no
sense. And I guess he's trying to say, if you take
a Lincoln statue down, it justifies changing the
constitution. And of course, the argument about
constitutional originalism or the Constitution as
a dynamic document that should be considered in
the context of the modern world. It has nothing
to do with Lincoln statues, but they see this.
This is the type of, you know, 90 percent of
the discourse on the right is now CRT bad. It's
OK to be white. Dr. Seuss's Good Elmo, Big Bird,
whatever the thing, that's 90 percent of it. The
other 10 percent is this type of thing which to
them is like as serious a discussion as you will
get now. I am not advocating for the political
views of the people I'm about to name, but just
to tell you guys that it wasn't always like this.
Go on YouTube and look up. William F. Buckley and
some of his debates go and look up. Thomas Soul.
I'm not saying these are people whose views
I agree with. I'm just giving you examples of
the fact that there used to be a different type
of thinking on the right where you could engage
substantively on issues more the way that you
know. Yesterday, when I spoke to former Republican
Congressman Joe Walsh, we were sort of able to do
to some degree, it doesn't have to be this stuff,
but that's all that's left at this point
in time. And if it if it works for them,
if it wins them elections, I can't imagine
any real reason that they would change that.